- Good morning Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe, and I believe
in people more than they
believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is "become irreplaceable."
Over to you, Priyanka Chopra.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- [Priyanka] When I was
very young, I was 19,
and I was doing the first
few movies I remember
the producers would say,
"Well, if she can't work it out
"it's fine. We'll just cast someone else,
"girls are replaceable."
Subconsciously, it
really worked on my mind,
and I started picking up
parts which were strong,
which were not just the damsel in distress
waiting for someone to rescue me.
Now 13, 15 years later the movies
that I do, I'm irreplaceable.
- If you want to be a success
in whatever you're doing
then you have to be so good at
it that you're irreplaceable.
If I can swap out your
product or your service
with somebody else's really easily
then you're never going to stand out,
you're never going to really
build a successful business.
It's going to be a race down
to the bottom for price.
If I can't tell the difference between
what you're selling and what
your competitors are selling
then I'm just going to go
with whoever is the cheapest.
And that's where a lot of
entrepreneurs are playing.
Now price is always going to be important,
but it's not always the
most important thing
for a majority of a lot of customers.
You just haven't done your
job to stand out enough.
I think it's also really important
to balance your ego with your humbleness.
I think it's important to have both.
I think a lot of entrepreneurs
and a lot of people play
on one side of the spectrum
and not enough of the other.
And so a lot of entrepreneurs,
we don't have enough ego,
we don't have enough pride, we
don't have enough confidence
in ourselves to go out and charge
what we're worth, to
feel like we're worthy.
I think a lot of entrepreneurs
could boost their prices
20, 25, 30% and not see
a dip in their customers.
I think too many entrepreneurs
just underprice themselves
because they don't have
enough confidence in what
they're selling and what they're doing.
I think too, though, you
balance it with humbleness
because if you are not humble
then you'll never grow.
And you'll never learn, and
you'll never try to get better,
and you'll never try to keep improving
because you think you know everything.
And so if I look at my
YouTube channel as an example,
I've had a number of conversations
with different people
talking about my channel,
and often it'll start with me saying all
the things that I want to work on.
Like I need to get better.
I need to create better content.
I need to make three solid
videos a day that people love
and every series is leading
to growth to the channel
and is having a big impact
on the audience reach.
And a lot of times the natural reaction
from people will be to try
to be supportive and say,
"Well, you're making three videos a day.
"I'm making one a week," or,
"I struggle to make one a week.
"You're already doing great.
You're already having such a
"big impact, you shouldn't
be so hard on yourself."
And this is where the danger comes in
because if I just lived
to their expectations,
You know, I'm just some
big fish in this tiny pond.
It's easy to feel good
about myself, right?
It's easy to say, "Well,
you know, you're right."
If I compare myself to all
these other YouTube channels
where they're making one video
a week and that's really hard
and that's really good for them
then I lower my standards
to where they're at
and what they see as excellent.
Or for me, I have greater
standards for myself.
And so I push myself to want to do more.
I believe the editing can be better.
I believe the filming can be better.
I believe I can be better.
I believe the content
we have can be better.
Everything can always be better
and that'll push ourselves
to go out and do it.
And at the same time, I think my channel
is the greatest YouTube channel, period.
I think my channel is a gift to humanity.
I think if a YouTube
channel was going to win
a Nobel prize it should be my channel.
I love my channel, I
consume my own channel more
than any other channel and I
think it's a gift to humanity,
I do, I believe that, and it
needs to get a lot better.
Right, so embracing both sides.
And so I think feeling that
same way about your business,
feeling like the work that you're doing
can always get better, can always improve.
You can improve your
skills and your hustle,
and your drive, and how
much practice you put in it,
and energy, and there's
always something new to learn.
You're never done learning, as soon
as you stop learning you're done.
And you're also providing a lot of value.
You have a great product
or a great service.
There's a lot of love that goes in.
There's a noticeable
difference between you
and somebody else, the
rest of your competition.
Feeling that because
if you don't feel that,
you're customers won't feel that either.
If somebody gets on the call
with you or meets with you
and you can't, with pride,
explain why you're different
and why you're better, and
for them to see that result.
If they can't see it they're
not going to pay you more,
they're not going to pick
you over somebody else.
And that means, ultimately, you can't grow
your business as big as it should be.
It's the balance, humbleness plus
ego/confidence become irreplaceable.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what is the thing that
makes you irreplaceable?
What's so special, unique, different
about your business that nobody
else can do just like you.
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
And also if you leave a comment
within the first couple hours
of this video going live
you have a chance of winning
one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Dev Gadhvi.
Dev, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
and doing a review on your
channel for your audience.
CareNation, for doing
the interview with Lily,
and all the love and support you've given
for my book, "Your One Word."
I really appreciate it man and I'm so glad
that you enjoyed the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself, and
whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- You know, in your life
you will start a job
and this is what I say that
every single new person coming
into Pixar, no matter what you do
make yourself indispensable
to that organization.
Make yourself indispensable.
Where people, after
you're done with your job
people cannot imagine
the place without you.
And without asking for a
thing your career will be set.
- You can be a history
maker or you can be liked
by everyone around you, you can't be both.
I mean the very nature of
living your personal greatness
and doing something
otherworldly in our world
of ours means you're going to have
to think differently from the majority.
You're going to have to install the habits
and routines that most people don't do.
You're going to have to live,
talk, breathe, walk, work,
produce, create in a way that most people
who are card carrying members of the cult
of mediocrity just don't buy into.
I mean you look at most
people out on the world today,
and this is not judging,
this is just reporting,
but they're addicted to
entertainment, they love gossiping.
They're negative. They're toxic.
Anyone who wants to do anything great,
they want to bring them down.
They dismiss the game changers
and they're just coasting through life.
And so the very nature of
you stepping up your game,
living your greatest
potential, owning your craft,
dominating your field, and
living a life that's legendary
means you're going to have to leave the 5%
and make a decision to
live as very few people do.
And what does that mean?
It means you're going to be laughed at.
It means you're going to be ridiculed.
It means you're going to be misunderstood
because leadership is a lonely sport.
And it means you just might be hated.
- We talk about coolers,
we talk about closers,
and we talk about cleaners.
Cleaners are going to get you
that end result over and over again.
They are so well prepared
and their instincts are
so sharp they already know what to do.
If there's a person that's
producing exceptionally,
there's a reason behind it.
It's the process, the constant
challenge to get there again,
and again, and again is what
drives these individuals.
Everyone talks about "We
want to be legendary."
You want to be iconic,
don't settle for legendary.